the most exciting thing in mental health
care right now is psychedelic therapies
because for once we have
really strategic pretty consistently
successful therapeutics that get down to
root cause issues versus treating the
symptoms
dr dan angle welcome to the show
ah it's good to be with you chris thanks
for having me on man i am very very
happy to have you here how do you
describe what you do for work
uh these days
the conceptual frame of that is
transformational medicine
which incorporates a lot of different
things and we could dissect that out but
i'd say that's the gist of it all right
how many mdma-assisted psychotherapy
sessions have you done like that you've
sat with or facilitated
oh
on or off the record
we're definitely on the record now um
but you can you can include whatever you
want
yeah um i have facilitated
i don't know now uh several hundred
different medicine sessions and i don't
know if i've even kept a track of which
ones are which different medicines
historically i've facilitated with quite
a few different medicines for people in
different contexts sometimes individuals
sometimes group
sometimes in the states sometimes out of
the states
there's a variety of different
contexts where we can do that legally
whether it's in a religious context or
if it's in a retreat context in places
where medicines are
legal and used
i live down in south america outside of
iquitos peru for about a year studying
with ayahuasca
in an apprenticeship and
that was 15 years ago when there wasn't
much really known or understood or
appreciated about ayahuasca and
at that time i really started to get
into the
the curiosity and the the fascination
with
how you have different levels of people
who can be supportive to another going
through a process you have sitters
you have therapists i.e facilitators
facilitators in more kind of a western
psychological framework and then you
have trackers
you know trackers that that really can
pick up the subtle nuances of the
landscape
and help people
rescue those
lost parts of themselves what are your
credentials
a medical doctor
yeah i've gone through
um medical school here in the states uh
my so that was in san antonio where i
grew up i did my psychiatry residency in
denver
uh that was three years then i did
two psych fellowships one in forensic
psych
and one in child psych and finish that
up in portland
and i've medical i've been the medical
director for let's see eight different
centers um
up to now and to the eve of what we were
just talking about launching kuya in
about two weeks is it rare for somebody
in the
plant medicine
world
to have this degree of western clinical
credentials as well
historically it's been very rare
uh thankfully it's growing
because
too in my experience
and when you go through medical school
and residency you end up studying all
the variety of fields and then you
specialize
and in the different specialty fields as
i was vetting what i wanted to get into
in my experience two of the most
pessimistic fields are neurology and
psychiatry and those are the two fields
that i ended up studying in because
everything was fascinating
and they have really revolutionized
since my medical training 20 years ago
and the most exciting thing in mental
health care right now is psychedelic
therapies because four once
we have
really strategic pretty consistently
successful therapeutics that get down to
root cause issues
versus
treating the symptoms
which has its place too for sure it's
good to be able to support people easing
their suffering
we also want to be able to use the
therapeutic tools that really get down
to the causative root factors the
symptoms would be your paxils your
zolofts your ssris yeah yeah
and with the medical model that we have
psychiatry you know psyche means soul
it translates to that terminology
historically it means mind too
and there are various aspects of the
mind one of which is this connection
with soul and you know
a soul is to spirit as a drop is to the
ocean you know we all have this
underlying
experience of what animates our being
and we as a field of psychiatry and
psychiatrists have largely sold out to
our role as a spokesperson and a
physician for the soul to the
pharmaceutical industry
and it's not to make that wrong it's
just to say that that's a particular
orientation we've kind of maxed out the
benefit at least
when you look at the numbers in the data
and if somebody's standing on the ledge
and all they have is
antidepressants and antipsychotics and
neuropsychopharmaceuticals available to
them i say we'll use the medicines
those are medicines every medicine has
its place
pharmaceuticals have their place
just like going to the er has its place
and going into the or if you need to get
under the knife or in that kind of
western triage care
like let's put you back together we're
really good at that that's what we do
really well
in western medicine however we're really
shitty at preventative care and chronic
care management
and so we're seeing this whole
reclamation of psychiatry as this deeper
aspect of getting to know the root cause
issues and having tools that can get
into the nitty-gritty
ideally being facilitated with people
who are good
trained experienced facilitators
and to
let the medicine work its magic because
often times as facilitators if we create
the safe environment the safe sentence
setting and people can really relax into
it trust it surrender into it
then
we offer the medicine and the medicine
does its magic and then and then it's
as much of the facilitator's role to not
get in the way
to not try and mess with it or think
that they need to do something because
the medicine is pretty phenomenal at
being able to help people get in touch
with the deepest aspects of their being
the medicine that we're going to be
talking about today mostly is mdma
what's the story of that how did it come
about
yeah it's a fascinating one mdmas
followed the trajectory of many
different medicines um you know this
whole field of psychedelic therapy is
now gaining more and more traction and
we could talk about the different
pantheon of medicines you have level one
medicines level two medicines level
three medicines
and just like you wouldn't go into the
gym
and put 300 on the squat rack and unless
you had worked up to that it's also
advisable to not start at a level three
medicine until okay so what uh what's a
one two and a three what would be some
examples of what sits in those brackets
yeah um so
before even that it's good to set the
foundation right get your stance correct
really understand your posture alignment
and
and that would look like meditation and
that would look like self-regulation
level zero now
that's ground zero that's the solid
foundation
and that might look like going into a
float tank and seeing if you can hold
your stuff together in a float tank
because if you can't hold it together in
a float tank it might be pretty hard to
hold it together in a ceremony
and so
what does it look like when we find our
conscious ability to chase our growth
edge and lean into our fear and get
intimate with that fear
and breathe through that and learn
self-regulation in the midst of fear and
in the midst of our core wounding
it's hard for us to do our tracking on
our own like we don't self-observe super
well as a species we're good at well
relatively depending on training and
kind of our gestalt or our constitution
ability to be able to do that for others
but traditionally it's
we're we don't do that super well for
ourselves and part of that's because we
have these awesome ego defenses that
keep our wounds kind of at bay
and when we start to learn that
the the things that the core wounds and
the things that we've really walled
ourselves off from they're actually
available to become our teachers
their their assets to us as our as our
weaknesses become our best strengths etc
and so this foundational experience
setting the the firm
um
ground matrix so to speak so that the
new growth can happen is oftentimes
through these neuroregulation
self-regulation practices meditation is
just one example of that
and so once we start to be able to
self-regulate then we can
opt-in to having
more altered state experiences and still
be able to find our center
or maintain a state
of available curiosity in the midst of
the
the ego's reflexive position to move
away from that which it fears what would
be an example of some of that trump
right so eventually this is part of the
preparation
so mdma to answer your question would be
a level one medicine okay i can share a
little bit about some of the others
and in that preparation process we can
onboard
the person going through that to
understand that
trauma can be a gateway to
transformation
like barbara mark subard says crisis
perceives transformation every time
and when we go through this experience
of being
reclaimed into wholeness
which means bringing all of these
separate parts home like the traumatized
parts of our self that might have been
locked away after trauma and trauma
doesn't have to mean like
being in
in war and on the battlefield or having
a near-death experience in a head-on
collision or
a variety of other light very obvious
life-threatening experiences that's
classic ptsd
but there's also this growing awareness
now over the last couple of decades of
what we would call complex ptsd
which is more of the accumulation of
adverse childhood experiences from very
young oftentimes which are before
memory
right so we didn't really consolidate
language with memory centers until we're
like four or five six years old
so so much that happens before that
which we're still configuring our
identity and persona
and view of ourself in the world happens
in these early formative years and we
might not have access to it so you're
saying that you're saying that we can
have something prior to our ability to
recall it
totally as a child which has impacted us
in terms of our trauma
throughout the rest of our lives
totally
how much
of the trauma that you see with
the people that you work with
comes from that
pre-memory phase versus a post-memory
phase
70 well part of it's a selection bias
because i don't only work with veterans
um but if i was take a random sampling
of the population i'd say it's about 60
to 70 percent
complex ptsd versus classic ptsd
presumably the complex ptsd is not just
the pre
memory phase though that there will be
the small eroding and chipping away over
time that contributes to that too
right
and and that small chipping away
oftentimes is
the
ero that's a good term the erosion of a
sense of safety and security in the
world a sense of being able to trust our
our
caregivers whoever that was if that was
our parents or our grandparents or
however we were raised can we trust the
bigger people when we're a little person
the bigger people just seem like gods
can we trust
those gods can we trust a god what's our
relationship with god what's our
relationship with life what's the
relationship with the planet
these are
the
the factors that go into establishing a
sense of safety and security and that
can get eroded
through these
experience and so it doesn't all have to
be like in the first four four or five
formative years it can be later too like
for example
say i'm in elementary school and have a
pretty safe secure a sense of my family
and
my attachment style
and i haven't been exposed to a whole
lot of trauma i've been loved a lot say
my family
moves to a totally different culture
totally different community and and
maybe i'm on the smaller side and now i
just start getting pummeled by the the
guys at school
that's going to leave a mark right so
but maybe it wasn't like i got so
thrashed that i almost died and there
was obvious trauma maybe it was just
bullying
and and and not to say just bullying not
to mean that bullying is just this oh
piddly thing that doesn't have
consequences
that can be significantly detrimental
to a growing person's sense of themself
in the world and how they trust
themselves and
and maybe if
if that gets utilized as a platform like
maybe i come home i tell that to my
parents and my parents are like okay
yeah i could see that that sucks you
know tell us about it how does that feel
let's get you into self-defense classes
let's get you into martial arts let's
get you maybe it's it's another
initiation right crisis proceeds
transformation every time
so maybe it was able to get worked
through and dealt with then but maybe it
didn't maybe i didn't feel like i could
tell anybody or my parents were thrashed
themselves because they moved and then
we lost all our money or they were
having trauma too and so we can just see
all the different
radically complex and beautifully
intricate scenarios and characteristics
of life that would
help us evolve into particular
experience of ourself so that's level
one
so mdma would be a level one medicine
and this is not an exhaustive list
but if we think about level one
medicines versus level two versus level
three
basically the differential would be
in part
level one medicines are typically easier
to navigate and with a higher likelihood
of having a positive experience
if you only had a sitter
supporting you in a safe environment
maybe you had facilitation or maybe your
sitter
knew how to support it more than just
helping you stay safe which is
the minimum viable product so to speak
to entering the space is make sure that
you have safety make sure that you know
and by you know i i should probably off
also preface like not everybody's ready
to have a medicine experience
that is
not everybody's ready to have a
psychedelic process occur
and that might be for a variety of
reasons too that we could speak about
like what are the contraindications
so ease of entry into the space ease of
experience of the space
high likelihood of a positive outcome
relatively short process
i'll speak about that a little bit
further and relatively
low
need for potential intervention by those
that are helping
to hold the container so level one
medicines mdma
ketamine
psilocybin
psilocybin would be in that list
dose dependent yep
yeah dose dependent lsd
that would be on the longer side i'm
going to guess we're talking sort of
upwards of maybe 10 hours there
right
so low-dose lsd you start to have what's
called a psycholytic experience so kind
of like ketamine in that you start to
open up what aldo sexually would
describe as the doors of perception you
start opening up the gateways
and low-dose lsd
100 micrograms 150 micrograms depending
that's also dependent on
a bit weight distribution
a bit
person's experience in altered states
um
a bit their
kind of metabolic profile a bit their
psychological armoring
because you can shut down experiences
too if you just will them away so to
speak
unless you jump up to like 500 to 600
micrograms of lsd that's just along for
the ride yeah right and that's a level
three process okay if you know the
differential with psilocybin you have a
one two gram experience that's a level
one typically for most people you have a
three to four gram experience that's a
level two for most people you have a
five gram and above experience now
you're getting into level three so some
of that's dose dependent and then the
fifth medicine is cannabis
cannabis is an amazing medicine we tend
to not use it much as a medicine these
days because it's now going so widely
recreational
very there are very many people who are
still using it as a medicine and so many
more and more people are using it as a
recreational
tool and i'm not here to say that that's
wrong or bad i'm just talking about the
difference between a recreational
engagement with a medicine versus a
therapeutic engagement and
in my experience no other medicine
highlights the differential there more
so than mdma
because you can take mdma
and go to a rave and hang out with your
friends and it can just be
so fun
ecstatic states really high
and oh by the way it's still illegal so
you have to know legalities and maybe
you're not even ready because it can be
a bit much depending on again dose
and also purity because people getting
stuff off the street that's called
ecstasy that's not mdma it's oftentimes
cut with a lot of stuff
and if you're working with pure molecule
then it can yes it engenders that joyful
process
that's a that's an ecstatic state which
we are driven for extasis we're driven
for transcendence
and that's a very different sentence
setting an intention going in versus a
therapeutic setting
using the same molecule
but i've had so many people tell me
that the experience between a
recreational process and a therapeutic
process felt to them like it was a
totally different molecule that they're
working with totally different
experience totally different
outcome that's interesting i'm
someone that's partaking in many of
those substances but most of them during
a party setting
so mdma especially throughout my 20s a
lot of that i don't think i've ever
taken mdma
and not had it with alcohol ever
i would be surprised and i've
been talking like
30 times 50 times
you could you could con
i wouldn't be surprised if it happened
to be 100 and i've just forgotten
another 50. um
but it's never been it's never been with
that in mind okay so that's what sort of
the dose-dependent stages would be are
there any compounds that aren't in
that aren't in level one
but are in level two and three i know
that some of them we can have same
compounds different doses yeah are there
other compounds
yep and i want to highlight something
you just said because it's a fascinating
experience that happens for most of us
the two biggest things that we don't
teach our youth
sex and drugs
and the two biggest things they're going
to explore on their own because we're
driven for creativity procreation
exploration rebellion and and hormones
are coming online and we're meant to be
rebels at that age and if we don't
express our healthy rebellion at the
teenage level it comes out later in
adulthood and it looks really [ __ ]
messy
right so
unfortunately we don't onboard our youth
with an understanding of how to
appreciate
and use these medicines and these all
states of consciousness and that
exploration in a healthy good way and
and so that it doesn't come out in a
distorted or destructive way
same thing with sex and having a
conscious in engaged
educational platform around healthy sex
and
you know i suppose we could use a bit of
a term that's been used more and more
lately like a sex positive culture a sex
positive educational platform
and so
you're highlighting something really
important like we're going to explore
altered states
90 of high school adults
in the u.s 90 of high school
seniors
say that they have experienced altered
states of consciousness with some degree
of
um significance
more than once
and with something that was not legal
because
in high school you're not even supposed
to drink alcohol at least in the states
um so it could be cannabis could be
alcohol could be mdma it could be lsd it
could be a whole sort of thing so that's
a
fairly significant number
right and and that's in a setting where
you're telling people not to most of the
time like don't do that friday
commercial i don't know if you remember
the
this is your brain on drugs friday
commercial i grew up in that era
and it worked but it was okay for at
least us in our culture to drink alcohol
we just couldn't smoke dope because
you're going to end up in a stupid
puddle for the rest of your life
if you did
and so when we have the opportunity to
to change the narrative and actually
have a an adult conversation with our
youth in a transparent way that lets
them ask questions and get curious about
it so that they have ownership of their
process and it doesn't have to happen in
in the shadows so to speak then
now we're going to start to have a new
orientation to consciousness
and
that's part of the reason that the war
on drugs was so
popular
in the 70s that took everything and put
it into schedule one including mdma
that happened a little bit later but
like lsd psilocybin
nixon administration
the
public enemy number one was the drugs
and so war on drugs happened
so to then peel it back to what you were
talking about in regards to the
recognition you've worked with this tool
in a different setting with other
tools on board alcohol can be an amazing
tool too but in our culture we typically
use it extraordinarily
poor
poorly mindlessly
and it creates an opportunity for people
to continue to numb out to their pain
because we don't have yet a medical
system that starts to get to the root
cause of the trauma
so
i get curious for you in that kind of
recognition like this is a medicine
you've known pretty
regularly throughout your 20s but in a
very different cocktail of experience
and
state dependent intention
so then to work with it as a therapeutic
tool you might quite likely have a very
different experience and mdma is a
phenomenal medicine in how it engenders
a therapeutic process because if you
were to construct
a neurochemical profile for a particular
agent
that's
so good
consistently
at helping to work with trauma you'd be
hard-pressed to find one better than
mdma
why because it's so
phenomenal so the way it works in this
in
neurochemically neuro anatomically
um
psychophysiologically
it
stimulates certain areas of the brain
as well as creating this awesome um
opening process through the
neuroendocrine cascade so the
neurohormonal cascade it releases and
floods the system with something called
oxytocin
oxytocin is our bonding hormone it's the
hormone that
mothers secrete
in breast milk when they're lactating
and breastfeeding their children and and
they're in this unification experience
this union experience so
oxytocin is very much a hormone of union
union with ourselves union with the
divine union with others
and
it also creates this
this neurochemical cascade through
primarily serotonin and norepinephrine
that it allows the
fear center to relax
that's also part of the oxytocin effect
because when you're flooded with union
fear typically is
relaxed and vice versa it's hard to be
flooded with union when your fear is
really
heightened
and so the amygdala starts to relax the
ego defenses start to relax so our fear
centers start to relax in the middle of
creating this really hyper alert state
so the neuro
the norepinephrine endocrine experience
of the prefrontal cortex allows us like
supreme witness to come on board and you
can track really well i mean you've
experienced it's a very energizing
medicine so it brings energy into this
it's also an amphetamine derivative so
it it tends to kick up the the energetic
profile feels like you've had a couple
of shots of coffee
and it also helps to
impregnate
a greater connection neuroanatomically
that that behaviorally expresses itself
as improved memory because you get a
really
heightened connection between the
prefrontal cortex and the hippocampus
where we hold our memories so three
things just happened
i've i've relaxed my fear center the
amygdala is downregulated i have a
better witness because the prefrontal
cortex is online and i have a better
memory because the hippocampus is more
online
so in the midst of all of that with with
my ego defenses now relaxed and my
unification that bonding hormone alive
now you've created this amazing
neurochemical soup
that
allows the curiosity and the
investigation of the things that we've
held back
that we were scared from maybe that we
didn't even know was there the trauma
starts to naturally bubble to the
surface and those things that i wouldn't
have let myself acknowledge or become
intimate with before are now coming up
and we can work with it
it creates a very appropriate
environment for a therapist to work in
bingo
especially for trauma
i mean pretty much for anything because
mdma is an amazing medicine for
communication it was in the early 80s
used for couples therapy predominantly
because it's just so good at helping us
drop our [ __ ] meter
and get real
but also speak from a place of truth
without so much defensiveness
or animosity
or um you the the subtle
communication
factors that
maybe that's passive-aggressive maybe
they're barbs maybe they're subtle
sabotage maybe it's like all of that
starts to now also relax all of those
historical ways that maybe we were
sideways or distorted in our
communication now we have the
opportunity to speak with more truth
clarity and
love
and so it's a great couples therapy
agent what about the story of mdma how
did it
get created
and then we'll come back and i'll say
more about level two level three etc so
um i think it was 1912 methylene dioxy
methamphetamine
so that's what mdma stands for and it
wasn't used for 50 or so years until
5060s it started becoming more widely
used and appreciated
and it became a strong psychotherapeutic
tool in the 70s and why was it created
in the first place um
it was created
yeah i i don't know
what initially the impulse was that
we're going to create this particular
molecule and it wasn't for a
psychotherapeutic aim back then in the
early 1900s we weren't really looking at
psychopharmacology at that time as a
tool into
like doorways of the mind so to speak
and then it got resurrected
and
that has its own kind of colorful story
that i'm probably not the best to
describe because there's a lot of um
circumstance and a lot of iterations to
that story of like how it just magically
kind of came back onto the scene
and
as i understand once it became more
widely used and appreciated
psychotherapeutically that was also in
parallel
late 50s into the 60s
coming into
our curiosity in the psychedelic
revolution that was happening at that
time psychedelics in general
and
it
it didn't get as much appreciation as
things like you know lsd was the front
runner
of the counterculture movement in the
late 60s
and then kind of back drafting all of
off of lsd's
kind of entry into the space was mdma
as not so much a psycho
psychoactive psychedelic experience
like lsd is a classic psychedelic
philosophy is a classic psychedelic
dmt based medicines ayahuasca is a
classic psychedelic
mdma is not mdma is described as an m
pathogen or intactogen
which means it engenders empathy
and it has all of those neurological and
neurochemical aspects and kind of
attributes that i mentioned
and
because it's so fascinatingly
powerful
in its ability to help people speak
their truth from a place of being
unguarded and essentially
more open and available to contact that
truth and then communicate it it's an
amazing psychotherapeutic tool so it was
being used more and more by the
psychotherapeutic community in the 70s
and into the early 80s
and never should have been in schedule
one
schedule one means that's r in the
united states classification of of
medicines that have no known
benefit and they're highly addictive
and those would be also we could call
street drugs like heroin cocaine
methamphetamine
but now we're talking about only a few
iterations off of the classic meth or
crystal meth which
just wrecks a lot of people's lives
you have not so far away from that
something like mdma which is saving a
lot of people's lives
so medicines oftentimes have
not only their sacred place at the table
like all medicines once we get to
understand what it's for
then we can understand how to use it in
a good way
and we can also start to not just
bastardize something like heroin which
is very similar to morphine which is
very good for helping many people with
intractable pain syndrome
i got part of my background in neurology
and
i've had a host of concussions and i've
helped people with traumatic brain
injuries and some of the sensors i've
run in the past that's been our focus
and neuropathic pain
sucks
having a chronic nerve injury like a
structural nerve firing
that is like an itch that you can't ever
scratch
it's this constant pain
like sciatica is a common experience of
neuropathic pain and most people have
sciatica right yeah that really sucks
well if you have that ongoing all the
time
it's a really rough day
and so that can be another aspect and a
potential
trajectory for transformational
experience and being able to work with
your mind
and it's also helpful to do that with an
opioid pharmaceutical like morphine
morphine was the first one on a
battlefield medicine was very good but
then you have something like heroin
that's just a little bit different
right
and now we have the differential between
a medicine and a drug
or if you look like something like
cocaine
ritalin is pharma pharmacologically very
much like cocaine
right and we give that
almost like m ms to youth to help them
sit still little johnny in the back
who's just got a lot of mental energy
maybe a lot of physical energy and he
learns by moving his body in space
everybody learns a little bit different
there's like at least seven different
primary learning styles
so
when we have a one-size-fits-all
educational model and we make kids
the problem because they're not just
gonna sit there like little minions and
stamp widgets for an hour at a time
because that's not how they're geared
then we start to
drug them with things that aren't that
pharmacologically different than the
things that we're bastardizing and
putting people in way in
privatized prison system for long
periods of time so we just start to see
how all of this is going through this
massive transformation it's not just the
medical industry through psychedelics
it's also the privatized prison system
and going through just social justice
reform it's also the political system
it's also
who's
right so there's a lot
a large downstream effect when we have
something like
the reclamation
of truth-telling
in what the war on drugs is actually
about
then it calls us into action to make
sure that we're doing our due diligence
to make sure that that doesn't happen
again to the best of our ability
because it's very clear that the nixon
administration public enemy number one
was that
was drugs
but
that was still
smoke and mirrors and kind of like the
front story
for the fact that they
wanted a control mechanism for
the minorities and they knew that they
if they could connect
the black community with heroin and they
could connect the hippies with cannabis
and make both of those illegal then they
could marginalize both of those
communities and continue to control
like status quo and so this whole war on
drugs was not based in
data in science it was based on
political motivations
and
we're seeing something similar in the
con
in the current global crisis with kovid
or with the last political election it's
hard to know which
data to trust on which
side of the poll
because you can have really good data
that sounds like legitimate truth and
you can have on one side you have really
good data it sounds like legitimate
truth on the other side
and so this is where
so much confusion and a sense of
paralysis can happen it's like [ __ ] i
don't know now who to trust and where to
go and like what are your
people like yourself doing podcasts and
like giving information to the masses
this is where it's a grassroots movement
to start
in mass demanding more truth-telling and
then finding those if we can't trust the
the political leaders and those that
quote above us are in charge then we'll
go to one another
and so mdma just like most of the
psychedelics is coming online right now
as one of my teachers would describe
them as clarigens
so mdma
now is going through this legal
um
how would i describe this it's uh
it's own transformation it's illegal
renaissance
yeah yeah we could call it a renaissance
yeah psychedelic therapy in general is
going through a renaissance for sure
mdma is even going through something
interesting because it is
such a a north star way shower of what's
possible
because it's so effective it's very safe
right
right though you just hit it on the hint
those are the two prime factors it's so
effective so people hear the stories of
transformation it's so safe so it's so
clear
that mdma doesn't belong in schedule one
it's saving people's lives
it's helping people reclaim
their trauma so as to be able to grow
from it and through it and with it to
become more whole humans
that's exactly what the field of
psychiatry is meant to do so it is this
way shower of what our potential is
in this renaissance so i think that's a
great word to use
let's get back to little let's get back
to level two and three i want to find
out
what's in that yeah where we're gonna go
is legalization with mdma
uh it's scheduled to become legal in the
next 18 to 24 months largely legal for
clinical
yep yeah yeah you just excited a lot of
people there thinking that it was going
to be
sold at the corner shop
right
and that's a totally different
orientation right because usually
drugs they go to
legal therapeutic use and then
potentially legal recreational use
cannabis did that right no one can use
it and now you can use it if you have a
diagnosis chronic pain syndrome ah and
now a lot of people are using it
recreationally because there's a lot of
money in it does this mean that there's
gonna be loads of dodgy street vendors
on venice beach flogging mdma cards
like i'll comment absolutely i hope
not can we get your mdmx therapy
card i certainly hope not it
i think there's going to be a much more
concerted rollout with maps and maps
relationship with the feds
and um that that you can because people
won't have like
in order to
sell it on the streets you'd have to
have it but nobody's going to be able to
have it outside of a licensed facility
so it's going to be under high
regulation and to to an extent we want
that
because we don't want to give any
ammunition to the feds
to prove their doubt that we're not
ready for this at least as a therapeutic
tool and then we can solidify that
safety and then talk about recreational
further down the road so
that's where we're headed um we
mentioned level one level two
typically
a bit
more
variables to take into consideration
a bit more of an intense process with
even an entry-level experience
can bring up more
shadow
work
to be able to do internally what does
that mean um
shadow so
like if you're if your trauma started
coming into the space and part of this
is because how the medicines are
facilitated the three level two
medicines ayahuasca peyote san pedro
they're not typically done individually
they're usually done in groups like
peyote's in a group studying ayahuasca
san pedro it's not typically oriented
for a person in the same kind of mdma
framework or therapeutic setting to do
one on work with
with those tools you can
but historically that's not its cultural
context and that's not the religious
context that the udv and santo daime
and the peyote way church they don't
hold it in the same kind of context and
you don't necessarily have to hold it
that way in order for it to be a legal
sanctioned
church
um congregational ceremony so to speak
um
but recognizing the lineage that these
medicines come from are
are
procured
and
offered
through
a tapestry and a technology
of consistent
facilitation
so there's a reason why those medicines
are facilitated that way and have been
done that way for hundreds and hundreds
of years
so
something like ayahuasca because it
translates into the vine of the soul or
the vine of death
and that's more of an ego death not a
physical death so people typically going
through an ayahuasca experience won't
die
but
that's another indication too that we
have to be even more clear in our contra
indications
because level 2 experiences can bring up
a lot of intense stuff
and if a person hasn't done a level one
process or if they haven't kind of
gotten their
solidification of being able to regulate
their nervous systems and they just pop
into an is ceremony a lot of people have
bad trips it really depends on the
setting the facilitation how much
they're given all of that
um
and
same thing with peyote and san pedro
because they're so strong and they last
so long it could be an uncomfortable
experience if people are having a rough
time and you just have to sweat it out
for a good eight to ten hours because
you might not have a facilitator
immediately right there that you can
just pull on like is usually how mdma
has worked usually it's in a group
setting so if you're having a hard time
you're typically going to have to just
sit with it and be with it
and
that's part of the benefit because it's
like resistance training
over time we get better and better at
being able to sit with our discomfort
and ayahuasca's my prime i would call
her as my primary teacher
the medicine that had the
strongest influence on my life
and when i came out of my
psychiatry fellowship had a clinic
was open for a couple of years we were
doing integrative psychiatry helping
people come off of psychiatric
medications so we were doing good work
but there was still a little bit of like
the depth of it missing and i was
introduced to ayahuasca circle
underground about 15 years ago and
i learned more about myself in one
weekend with ayahuasca then i hadn't won
decorative psychotherapy i was like
holy [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] has this been and why
haven't i heard about it i was both
fascinated and pissed
because i had spent close to 20 years
studying the mind and never come across
this
and so i closed up my clinic and moved
out of the jungle just because i was
fascinated
yeah
totally um so that i level two to the
extent that
if you're a facilitator entry level
if you're a sitter or an entry-level
facilitator you can support people
through a level one process
pretty routinely pretty successfully
but to facilitate ayahuasca peyote or
san pedro
usually my teachers would go through
a decade of training before they ever
worked on behalf of another
just consistently apprenticing
consistently learning understanding the
medicine understanding the astral plane
understanding the energetic profile
understanding how to
go into a person's field to be able to
track what they're not able to see on
their own
come back present that help them
integrate it and then dust off clean off
so that we're not taking on their
residue or the same i'm not influencing
their in their experience with my own
impact
so there are so many different nuances
of this kind of work and doing that
level of
curenderismo or vegetalismo or you know
my teachers wouldn't even describe
themselves as shamans because it's a
term from a different culture
but the healers of that traditional path
are those that know how to make a right
relationship with the medicines than and
the the herbs the plants and be able to
work
side by side hand in hand with that
technology on behalf of a client or a
group of people
that is
next level mastery so that's why i put
that in those in schedule or uh level
two so then we have level three
dmt andy boga
dmt because nothing will invite your ego
to die quite like dmt will especially if
it's in the smoked version
of either an ndmt five amio dmt
whether it's synthetic or
organic like from the sonoran desert
toad
it's so fast it's so strong it just
catapults your your ego straight out of
your body and it can happen so fast that
it feels really freaky
and i've worked with clients who
had their first psychedelic state with a
5 am experience and
and were shattered
for months afterwards what does that
mean because it just started
it just blew their doors open like if we
use that same kind of like gates of
perception doors of perception well you
can unlock the door or you can dynamite
the door blast them off the hinges yeah
exactly
right and so
that has a particular psychological
psychic and energetic impact
it really frays the energy body and this
gets more into like ayurveda if you're
talking about the naughties or like the
energetic body
um
or like astral tear in the field so to
speak like it requires surgical
intervention of a particular like now
we're now we're being interventionists
to the mind and to that degree of trauma
but it's not just psychological
there's a neurological there's an
energetic experience too so we
in the worst case scenario somebody gets
their doors blasted open and they can
get psychotic
or have intractable insomnia and
intractable insomnia will lead to
psychosis eventually
and so we might need to use a
psychopharmaceutical like antipsychotic
like
seroquel
and the list is long but just as
examples
and
that's where
that's a good example of if we need to
shut down the symptoms that we can and
so we have tools for that kind of
intervention ideally
if we come back to the rubric you don't
start at level three if i walked into a
i can't squat 300 pounds i used to be
able to but i'm just not in i'm not
doing those kinds of exercises like i
did before i can perform in ways now
that i didn't do before but you have to
understand where you're at and you have
to work up to that level
so dmt because it's so strong and it has
that impact for creating trauma and the
last thing we want to do is that we're
actually wanting to heal trauma
and iboga because it lasts so long and
it's so arduous how long is a boga
what's in a booga trip like
it's about 18 to 36 hours 36 hours jesus
[ __ ]
mine was both of mine were 40
and
it's fascinating because it
there's so much to do in that time
there's lifetimes of work to do in that
time but it also is a really intense
process
and the reason i said both of mine were
40 i did it
i was at a one center so the reason i
got into this work
more
kind of front and center and it's in the
front part of the dose of hope is
because my sister committed suicide
and that was from a long
long standing
battle
with depression
and alcohol all stemming from ptsd
that really wasn't acknowledged and we
didn't know much about it then and that
was also about 10 years ago
we didn't know i didn't know and i don't
think we knew as a culture as much about
complex ptsd and
mdma wasn't as available then and i was
a puritan in the ayahuasca path so i
didn't even know about mdma i didn't
even know about iboga i was just doing
my alaska
um like a pr like
the the i was still in school and i was
just pure on that path
and then she left i was like [ __ ] man
i know there's
more medicines available
i wish i would have known more about all
of the variety of medicines to be able
to support her
and so
that's when i journeyed into iboga
because iboga is the best medicine for
addiction recovery on the planet period
the best single agent
and it's because of how it works
pharmacologically also
energetically
psychically in the astral planes and
beyond for sure
but predominantly
how it works
neurochemically it works on 50 plus
different receptor profiles it goes in
there like a brillo pad and scrubs the
opioid receptors clean so if somebody
goes through an ebola experience or an
ibogaine experience
they don't have withdrawals and they
don't have cravings
it's crazy there's nothing else like
that on the planet
and when i say they it's not 100 it's
usually about 75 80 percent of people
don't have cravings and don't have
withdrawals
and i ran i was the medical director of
ibegin center in mexico for a year and
it was just phenomenal to see people
that had been daily
users of heroin or pain meds they
couldn't get off of
and just
so scared
to stop because the withdrawals are so
strong
or they tried so many times and failed
and now they're
people that are daily users for 10 plus
years go through one experience
done
it just blew my mind about what's
possible
and so
i wanted to understand it first form
that was i didn't get into medically
directing that center until i had my own
experience because i i wanted to have my
own experience first i knew i wouldn't
be able to support people going through
a process if i hadn't had that
experience so
i had in a bogey experience down in
costa rica it was 40 hours i was like
that was just a [ __ ] marathon and
then i had the i had the thought like
wow it can't be that way the next time
so i did it a few days later and it was
still 40 hours
not everybody's 40 hours but man it's
it's strong long
beautiful
um aubrey describes it we were talking
about a mutual friend of ours he like if
you're an ant on god's tuning fork and
he just goes pow and you're just
vibrating uncontrollably at that
cellular level psychic level somatic
level
for 18 plus hours so it's a long ride
but it's fascinating too because it's an
it's called what it's it's what's called
an o nerogen
so it's a dream medicine
it takes us into this dream time
so we have consistently
this review of our principal life
experiences
and the medicine will convey this
communication with the deepest aspects
of our own being i.e our soul about
what's in alignment in our life and
what's out of alignment and so it's very
clear at the end of that what our
marching orders are what our homework is
and again
down at crossroads i we would see a lot
of people that never had a psychedelic
experience so they're coming straight
into a level three but they're doing
that in a very controlled environment
and because they're
there's massive risk if they don't do
that treatment yeah because daily opioid
use has a massive head with a bad trip
continuing to use heroin every day seems
like a
right walk in the park yeah yeah yeah so
now you get a sense of
and that's by the way that's nobody
else's system or rubric that's just mine
and other people might have differing
opinions and
and but this is where i get excited
about having open
label kind of open source conversations
because we're creating
the new system of transformational
medicine and that includes the
understanding and ability to be able to
assess which medicine to use for which
person at which time
talk me through what an mdma assisted
psychotherapy session feels like
from someone arriving at the place to
getting in the chair to taking the drug
how's it administered what happens what
the sort of conversations take me
through that
totally well that's why i wrote the book
because there's a lot of information in
there
but the cliff notes version
is
so the way that maps has done it and i
think they've done a good job
they've essentially set the
the
process platform
for mdma is going to get rolled out and
and the success rate's phenomenal
if you look at phase 1 trials 80 83
success rate
cure for chronic severe ptsd
nothing like that on the planet
you look at phase 2 trials and it's like
60 65
curate still pretty good a little bit
lower
and then you're looking at phase 3
trials and it's about in the middle
plus percent so we're looking at like
two-thirds three-fourths of all people
with chronics of your ptsd
go through two to three sessions
and they're done
this is compared with a 34
improvement rate which is the other
alternative
that's the standard of care standard of
care psychopharmaceuticals talk therapy
and that has a 35 40 improvement rate
so we're not we're talking about a
differential in cure rate
versus improvement so the numbers are
even differential but the
exponentially different because we're
talking about improvement versus cure
so
the reason i say all of that is the
prelude to your conversation your
question is because
the
the data and those numbers
are largely not
just because of mdma because mdma is so
amazing it's how it's offered and what's
happening around the sessions too
because it's not just the sessions
you have 12 psychotherapy sessions
interwoven
with three medicine sessions
right so you have three medicine
sessions you have three therapy three
therapy three therapy three therapy
before interspersed and then after the
last one so you have 12 psychotherapy
sessions around three medicine sessions
so you have 15 sessions
and those medicine sessions are with
both of your therapists because it's a
dyad man woman ideally
and the therapy sessions are oftentimes
with dyad's too
so but not it doesn't have to be
it's either your primary therapist or
the diet therapist so now you've got so
much
investment and involvement in people
like really
in your business but also helping you
get clear
on
right self-regulation expectation
setting the stage understanding what the
process is going to be like that's why
i'm going to answer your question but i
want to just set the stage too like it's
important
for us to realize that when this
medicine goes legal it's going to be
mandated to have that degree of
psychotherapeutic engagement before
during and after
and unfortunately because insurance
companies are not reimbursing for this
right now it's going to be like 10 to 12
000 out of pocket
and now all of a sudden you've just now
made this a very
rare medicine that a chosen few are
going to be able to pay for so we're in
the midst of rehabilitating the entire
medical
reimbursement system to be able to
support those that need it the most to
be able to have access that's going to
roll out over time but there's a
concerted effort to doing that right now
i'm going to guess that that cost
can't change a massive amount because
you require two people who are very
experienced for a significant amount of
time over 12 sessions plus presumably
background checks testing
checking in with the client so on and so
forth so the only way really that that
cost can be brought down
significantly is with adding more
trainers in or more facilitators and
more therapists into the system so that
you can actually have a little bit more
um employment competition
or it being just an assistance by
insurance companies
i think both are going to happen yep
and i think i think also the cost is
going to come down because some of that
cost includes um
payment for research
and also there's a contribution to
research from everybody's
session yeah that's kind of cool that's
kind of like a
by by taking on the therapy yourself you
contribute to the benefit of other
people getting it in future that's quite
altruistic and cool
right it's kind of like phase one two
and three studies
have had that same kind of ethos and
that's what we do for for the benefit of
medical knowledge and research
so
that's the framework
what is what does it look like feel like
so
when you go through an mdma session it
feels like you you have the felt
experience of remembering what mdma is
like really it feels like a few red
bulls or a lot of coffee like your
system's amped
uh your heart rate and blood pressure
knock up about 20 points each
so one of the contraindications is heart
disease
another contraindication would be
intractable epilepsy
um people on psychopharmaceuticals are
ready so you can't be on
psycho psychiatric medications when
going through mdma it's a clear
conjugate indication
um people with a history of psychosis or
mania not a good idea to open up the
doors of perception even further so
there are a few cardinal
contraindications so the felt experience
it comes on
you get really aware
and you start to feel
what we could essentially describe as
love
ease
comfort safety bonding curiosity
openness
maybe a more neutral word would be open
versus love i think they're very
synonymous
so that opening feeling
with the alertness and the curiosity
with the facilitator who knows
at least some of your background and
trauma narrative well at least three
sessions right before the first time
that you do
at least three sessions ideally
longer ideally more ideally people have
a therapist or or a coach mentor guide
some kind of elder
or somebody that they're able to talk
with that knows them that's here for
them that consistently offers that
safety and security in a connective
supportive positive relationship
to be able to
be the person to help them land the
plane so to speak after all this
so
when that's all in place then you have
the ability to go even further and
deeper and wider and know that you're
going to be held on the other side
so you can get really open and you can
get really radically vulnerable
with whatever is just right underneath
the surface so we don't really have to
go as facilitators fishing
for what we think
is the deeper material like let's trust
the process
it's kind of like peeling back the
curtain and seeing what's right there do
you maybe
a lot of the time that your patients are
bringing up the most pertinent most
important stuff on their own
it may be
it may be the core wound
is right under the surface
it may be that
the core wound is expressing itself
through something more recent
or maybe even something a little less
intense like let's just test the waters
and make sure that this is safe to get
through like can you hold me through
this
if you can hold me through this
i'm not ready you're not ready we're not
ready to get into
the trenches
and and really dredge the the riverbanks
and in my experience once we've done the
preparation work it's usually pretty
close right
yeah yeah okay so somebody's lying there
you have this dyad this dear logos
that's going on which is
typically masculine and feminine to
reflect masculine and feminine energy is
the person lying eyes closed with the
towel on are you allowing them to
intersperse talking with you with music
what's happening there
yeah yeah great question
so
because the
medicine has a little bit of an arc to
come on
it comes on over the course of
about an hour depending a little bit on
the dose depending depends if you get
shitty drugs from a guy in an ibiza
nightclub sometimes it doesn't come on
all night
good point
so so let's assume that you're getting
good molecule yeah
it comes on and you get to cruise
altitude at around the hour mark
so that can be nice to have a person
with a blindfold
with a playlist with a curated playlist
no vocals no words especially in their
native language something that's really
soothing and just generally opening and
gradually opening for that hour
and then invite them to
come out of the
the at least the music oftentimes keep
the
blindfold on
and start checking in
how's it going how are you feeling
are you noticing anything
and and ask it ask open ended questions
and let them just start
some people will still be pretty silent
and some people will be just jabber
boxes
and and and if somebody's just like you
know going for it like the the verbal
psychic hose is open
in the on position great then let's just
harvest and let's like what's that like
what's that like tell me more like okay
great is there anything deeper
is there anything under that
and then when we start getting and you
can start telling you you can just read
the
the trauma narrative the trauma
languaging the somatic experience if
we're at the core issue and if we're
there then we'll explore that
and if they're if we get the sense
there's something deeper
great is there anything below that is
there anything behind that or if it's
about a particular cardinal person in
their lives can we understand what that
relationship was like for you what the
experience was like for you
and then eventually it oftentimes gets
it gets to this place like okay can we
understand the experience from their
position
so not to only go through the healing of
it but actually also to be able to have
a compassionate view and a greater
understanding as to how they were
involved in that too like oh my dad yeah
he was a dick
you know he did x y and z or he didn't
love me in the way that i wanted him to
or like all these things and then
let me just be clear that was my
experience
in a healing process with my dad
i had this vision like my dad needed to
love me a particular way or my dad was
largely
like the mar
a combination of the marlboro man and a
cia agent
and i was always trying to as a little
dude and i didn't grow up with my mom
and dad i just visited him occasionally
like every other weekend just constantly
trying to do enough to just get his
kudos
and
and that's largely what generated so
much performance and but there was also
this resentment like wow
it's like i always had to work for it
and then in one of my ceremonies this is
actually when i was doing my
apprenticeship this is with ayahuasca
but this is the same kind of trauma
recovery that happens with mdma too
i saw him
as a child and the fact that he didn't
he wasn't raised by either either of his
parents
he was raised by his grandmother she was
amazing
but neither of his parents were really
ready to be parents
and
and i think there was an experience of
rejection and it was just like a hard
road for him early on so he was largely
self-made
and just kind of grinned and
just knuckled down and like a lot of our
parents and grandparents did just
pushed on head down push on move through
and thankfully this is why i described
this process as the privilege to heal
we have this growing privilege to heal
we have these tools that many of our
ancestors didn't have
and so we're carrying a lot of their
burdens and traumas
so when we can get to a place
particularly with our parents it's like
okay what's behind that what's behind it
from their side what was their
experience like where did that come from
because
oftentimes transgenerational trauma
happens in a way that feels like ours
but when you get under the hood we
realize it didn't start with us it's
still ours to heal
and it's a and it's part of the
privilege to heal it because now we can
heal something our ancestors have been
carrying that they just weren't able to
access the tools for it's a little bit
like being a bookstop you know you have
corey mutual friend of ours he talks
about um
when someone gets angry at him
and he often thinks of it like a virus
so he thinks i wonder who gave you that
anger and i wonder who gave them that
anger and i wonder who gave them that
anger and it gets passed down and passed
down and passed down and he talks about
it in a mindfulness setting and he says
the mindfulness gap the beauty of being
able to have a beat pause between
stimulus and response to choose whether
or not you want to take that anger and
then pass it down to the next person
that you see that day that cut you up in
traffic or serves you the wrong drink in
starbucks
that's your choice and you are right
there there is a degree of privilege
there that you think right there's this
virus this
whatever this transgenerational trauma
which is being passed down my
mother's mother and her mother and the
mother before have all been like this
but i'm not going to be like that and i
have the opportunity
to
take the beat to use this mindfulness
gap or to use
some psychotherapy assisted by
a medicine to
yeah to stop that yeah it's a it's a
beautiful opportunity to have that
this may be um
my party background talking but my
recall
from times on mdma has been sketchy to
say the least
is there a difficulty with integrating
the lessons that people learn whilst
they're on mdma
because of the fact that
well i mean
how much of that's because the fact i
was drunk
and is there a difficulty with recall
for sure it's a great question
and
you're highlighting one of the
the
beauties and the challenges with this
kind of work
because it it engenders an altered state
so by definition we're not in our usual
kind of frame of mind
and so
all of the experience is cataloged
through a different veil and energetic
of consciousness so to speak so we have
to pierce that veil and be able to
access those files it's kind of like
it's kind of like that experience is
held on an external hard drive
and we have it on the hard drive we just
have to know how to like wormhole back
to it
and so i think a few things are relevant
to your question and your experience
alcohol has a huge impact on memory we
know that
and i imagine there wasn't just like a
swig here and there there was probably
a healthy i was sending it i was fully
sending it yeah right
so that's going to have an effect the
setting is going to have an effect
particularly in a party setting there's
so much energy and attention outward
and the feedback experience is very much
in
the middle world in the outer world
right and in a therapeutic setting it's
very much in the internal world in the
curious landscape where you're actually
having the input that's coming
towards you is one of
facilitating awareness
versus in a party scene oftentimes the
input that's coming in isn't
facilitating inner awareness it's
facility
they think what people are looking for
when they take mdma at a party is to
enhance that collective effervescence
right that's exactly they're looking to
you hear people use the terminology i
lost myself in the music
right
as opposed to finding yourself in you
which is
what you guys are trying to do so that
the framing the set and setting
um
focusing the attention
inwardly or outwardly that's that's an
interesting insight
yeah
because it's it's a medicine of opening
right so you're going to open to
something that's happening externally
the the collective the music the vibe
that energetic or are we going to open
to what's internal and when you have a
facilitator that's constantly
referencing you to the internal
it's really helpful
and oftentimes helping you get back on
the track because it's like you can be
open and get down a wormhole of your
mind that's not super helpful
or it's not like getting to the root
cause of the issue that you've come in
for so the therapist can and guide can
oftentimes like bring it back to that
common thread
and so
the experience
with mdma is usually around four to six
hours
um if you level up again the entry dose
is usually around 120 milligrams the the
level up after two hours is about half
of that dose
and then it turns into a six to eight
hour experience so it depends on the
time signature and how much there's
there is to go through most people will
re-up
um particularly
a lot of important work is
is getting done like i've done all this
prep work to get to here so i'm going to
get as much out of it as i can yeah and
oftentimes it can feel really pleasant
especially if somebody's been really
walled off and gartered and guarded and
the psychic armor has been heavy
not to say that trauma work
is pleasant
but there's uh
an experience that can that can feel
affirming
and
and strengthening liberating as well i
imagine yeah and liberating yeah like
wow and oftentimes doesn't feel
liberating in the moment
well cancer clay it very much can
especially if you're if you're
consciously engaging the process of
recognizing the lightness that comes
from shedding the old story and being
able to see it in a new light
so that can feel both not only
strengthening but very much liberating
yeah totally
talk to me about
reintegration and the end of it because
i've had some [ __ ] brutal come downs
in my time and
i
i don't want to be i don't want to be
ordering a dominoes to the mdma center
and asking them to turn off the lights
and and
send me a like a packet of coca-cola in
or something
right totally
and so by the come down and the
integration you mean like how you felt
afterwards correct
yeah
and so when we talk about integration
um
if you're in a recreational setting
integration is primarily around how you
feel
right versus if you're in a therapeutic
setting integration is very much about
what you learned
right so the integration is kind of like
let's harvest
we can often times benefit the
integration by typing recording the
session
and then going back to the notes
because now you have it all your hard
drives right there in a live and you can
just like
plug in your thumb drive
versus it being stuck in a particular
file that you have to actively
investigate potentially even with the
help of a facilitator or a member
because that facilitator is going to cue
you because they're tracking your
process they're going to be like oh so
tell me more about
how that
how going through that experience was
so they can drill down when you're in a
slightly different conscious state yeah
because i suppose having the
facilitators there
one of the worst things about
recreationally taking any of these sort
of compounds especially let's say
psilocybin which i i think people are
starting to take mushrooms just on their
own someone's interested their own
consciousness this is why i've taken it
before but i haven't take it in a fully
qualified therapeutic setting and one of
the brutal things about that is that as
you're having the experience and some
interesting insights come to you the
onus is on you to be able to recall them
once you're out of it and there's a
certain degree of pressure that sits
below the surface where you you see
something or you realize something or
you you notice something and you go
right that's that's [ __ ] awesome and
you try and get the pad and pen out
before
your mind falls away from it and i
remember
particularly trying to
try to write something down and as i was
writing it on my my pad and paper i
looked at my arm and the colors of my
arm looked like tiger's arms and i went
back to look at what i wrote down and it
wasn't the thing that i put before i
just wrote my arms my arms look like
tiger's arms i'm like no that wasn't the
one that i meant i meant the [ __ ]
interesting insight about my soul not
the fact that i have arms that look like
tiger's arms
totally i just solved the riddle of the
universe yeah exactly [ __ ]
right
so it can be helpful to record to audio
record that versus trying to transcribe
so much because that that motor
system might be a bit offline
and
when we have a facilitator that's able
to help us track it
or the audio recording that's able to
help us track then we can stay more
actively in the process and we're not
trying to have a part of our brain
that's tracking it and a part of our
brain that's medical science gets let
get rid of yeah
exactly
yeah
and so the integration sessions are
really about harvesting
and and going through that
and looking at the the principal themes
looking at
the areas that perhaps we were really
able to get in pretty easily
or those things that we really wanted to
stay away from
but then gradually opened up
what was the pacing of it what was the
energetic tone of it
how am i feeling coming out of it so
that's another thing that we'll get to
and all of that starts to turn into
the new story
because ultimately at the end of the day
with these as clarigens
seeing the deeper aspect of our being
reclaiming these parts of our self that
our ego has been so focused on
consciously or not suppressed or
repressed
now we're liberated from that
and even more empowered to write the new
story
to create the new
self-image to create the new
relationship with life relationship with
our partners
this is something that interests me so
i can fully appreciate why the use of
mdma creates an environment in which
someone can
feel comfortable enough to talk about
the traumas you have the facilitators
there who are able to draw out of them
in a professional setting and kind of
guide them to the the answers and the
questions that they need to be asking
themselves
but how does this contribute to lasting
lifestyle change long term once you're
out of this session
you're you're now hitting it on the head
this is where the rubber meets the road
if we were to talk about in a pie shaped
distribution of like the energetic
uh
priority
uh like like if you had so many marbles
in a jar like how much how many of those
marbles are going to preparation
experience and integration
it's about a
five to ten percent preparation
uh
thirty to forty percent experience
fifty to sixty percent integration
the majority of the work
happens in the integration because
that's where we make lasting change
and this is where it's vital to have
some kind of truth-telling
process
because if you go through an experience
and you and you learn the riddle of the
universe and you forget it
that's a big [ __ ] bummer
and so you want to have some kind of
truth-telling recording
device or process and you want to have
an accountability structure
so now how am i going to hold myself
accountable how's my therapist going to
hold me accountable how's my coach my
guide
going to hold me accountable for acting
on that truth
because
we can't unlearn we just learned you
won't unsee what you just saw
right now it's open the genie's out of
the bottle like now
and usually what that means is now
taking more ownership and responsibility
and that has its opportunity massive
payoff
for benefit
but it also has some detriment because
if we start taking massive
responsibility for our life that means
we can't blame anybody else
for our experiences
and so there's there can be a lot of
um
processing the grief in order to get
mature and
now
like what what life was lost because i
was maybe you know orienting towards all
of these things that i now realize were
were not um
the the greater deeper more integrated
aspects of myself but maybe all that was
exactly what needed to happen for me to
get here right so there's so much
reconfiguration now that happens in the
worldview selfie live view
having an accountability structure to be
able to act on that truth act on those
new choices is vital
and then the third thing is having a
positive community
a community around
not necessarily this kind of work it
could be
for sure yeah i so over the last three
years i created um a platform called
full spectrum medicine
and every week we would do integration
calls because i because it was clear
that so many people were going through
experiences and getting just way out
there and maybe big things happening but
didn't have any integration support and
so it's like floundering around so i it
was free i'm not doing it right now
because i'm launching kuya so i put that
on pause but we cataloged
18 months of
our video recordings all on integration
support for free just to have a safe
place for people to come experience
a community of transformation growing
and evolving together and supporting
each other
we'd have anywhere from it was
relatively small
um at any one time there was probably
between
20 and 80 participants on a zoom call
platform and we'd have people cycle in
and out and we'd record all of the i
would share topics of integration
like um
tools strategies
techniques things to do
things to not do as well
and then we would do question and answer
at the end and we have somebody in the
power seat that might be going through a
really challenging process with their
integration
and i would support them
coaching them through it while the rest
of the group was kind of
looking
in as as sacred witnesses so to speak
and i've trained a bunch of facilitation
guides to do this kind of work so i
so a lot of that community was a variety
of people some people just kind of
casually exploring some people guiding
facilitating others so it was a really
rich conversation
and and the community piece is vital
because for me i know when i started
waking up so to speak with ayahuasca i
realized
man i love a lot of my friends
and a lot of them are not on the same
trajectory anymore
and it wasn't a make wrong it wasn't
like i was better and they were worse it
was just like i'm going down this path
and this path is really vital and that
included like
saying no to a daily cannabis habit that
i had had for five years
and my my
riding buddies and my climbing buddies
and my
my
party buddies you know we i had so much
fun with those guys but it was clear
that i was going and i also moved out of
the country and down to the jungle and
everybody thought i was just off my
freaking rocker so it was clear that it
was easy for me to plug into a different
community but the reason i'm just
bringing that up is oftentimes it's
really freaking hard for people
when they start going through a process
of waking up and and reclaiming
ownership power responsibility and you
look around you're like okay is are
those the kind of values and virtues
that
that my current tribe is vibing at
are they supporting the growth that i'm
going through am i feeling like they're
like wind at my back or they kind of
like lead weights
and it can be a it can be a hard road if
it feels like the community is not
supporting the trajectory that you want
to take
what would be
some of the characteristics of the type
of person who wouldn't succeed
at mdma assisted psychotherapy what
would be the sort of things that they
would do
afterward how would they integrate
sub-optimally how would they enter the
session sub-optimally what would be some
of those things
[Music]
that's a
phenomenal question
um
if i was to recognize
if i was if i was to translate your
question
into a way that i could make more
context and answer more clearly i would
say like what might
be
the factors that would set up a less
than optimal mdma experience to happen
and then to get integrated
and i would say okay the facilitation is
lousy
right so they're not going to be able to
hold a strong accountability structure
like if i go into the gym and i know i'm
working on performance measures i want
to coach that's going to hold me
accountable that's going to help me see
like where i was and where i'm getting
to
um
and but most facilitation with mdma
because of the legal structure they have
to be good
in the states all of it right now is
happening with clinical trials but there
are a lot of underground
facilitators who aren't that good maybe
they're good sitters but they might not
be not be very good facilitators so if
deep trauma comes into the space and the
container can't hold it and the
facilitation can't hold it then it can
get messy and now you've got all this
trauma re-wounding in the space
impregnating the field but it's not
getting worked through
so it's like well that's great now i'm
just left with all this mess and i like
who's gonna help me clean it up
so that can be a factor
another factor can be um
the expectation that the medicine is
going to fix something
because the medicines are not here to
fix anything
they're here to show us truth
and they're here to help support us do
our work in order to become more whole
humans
and if a person thinks that they're
going to go through a process and
they're just going to magically pop out
the other side awesome and life's
awesome and they're not willing to put
in the work
then that expectation can be a handicap
and that expectation can also
potentially look like they they think
the work is going to be easy
sometimes the work's not freaking easy
like what started me on the ayahuasca
path was a prayer that helped me open up
my heart
i was going through a separation and
divorce and i couldn't feel it
and i didn't want to live that way
so
i didn't realize the answer to that
prayer was going to be eight years of
going through all the trauma that had
shut off my heart in the first place
so there were times in the integration
where i thought like this isn't supposed
to be happening
this wasn't in the fine print [ __ ] so
you know so i blew a fuse something's
off were were you know in a nosedive
and that was just an expectation of what
i thought was gonna happen didn't happen
it happened in a different way it
happened in a better way it happened in
a way that i wouldn't have chosen but
was orchestrated for my best outcome and
it's helpful to have a validation
team and community to lift each other up
to reference the growth that we're doing
together to be a little cheer to be able
to cheer lead each other on because this
isn't easy work
there is a massive amount of global
calamity and crisis and pain happening
that's not just current
that's mountains of unhealed residue
from past traumas from past cultural
traumas global traumas
a ton of trauma is getting brought
current
right now so by no means is this easy
work and we need to be in communities
where we're lifting each other up in
order to do the good work so that we can
unburden our children and the coming
generations from having to carry our
[ __ ] because they're going to have a lot
on their hands without carrying our
stuff too
to deal with you can have your work cut
out over the next few years then
i think probably so
what is the road map for the next i
think it seems like the next 18 months
or so are going to be pretty exciting
what's the road map that you see from
here on out for mdma assisted
psychotherapy
yeah i think your point's a good one
we've got a lot of good work uh and
ideally fun ahead too
um i do have a very clear sense that if
if if this isn't fun then
then we're missing some of it
because
if you can't make mdma fun
right i mean it's a pretty forgiving
medicine it has a phenomenal success
rate um it's amazing to see people go
from being really walled off and hurt
and in the semantic experience of trauma
to being really free
and really released and really available
to work through that trauma not to say
again that it's fixed and done
but it's it's pretty magical to help
people go through these kind of
processes so i think we're gonna train
uh i am not i'm i'm a spokesperson an
educator or an advocate for this
work i'm not formally affiliated with
the maps organization that's that's
involved in doing the majority of the
training
uh i support their organization for sure
and without them we wouldn't be having
this conversation
so they're
in charge of training as many
facilitators as possible and we're going
to need somewhere on the order of
50
plus thousand facilitators over the next
five to ten years and we're gonna have
five to six thousand
centers doing this kind of work over the
next five to ten years
we're going to gradually roll out this
medicine and this next wave of the
psychedelic and psychiatric renaissance
with medicine work we're going to
continue to roll that out as the new
growing standard of care i see
allopathic western medicine
has turned largely into functional
medicine when it's done well but it's
still relatively reductionistic and now
functional medicine is turning into
transformational medicine
which is like now we're going to have
the data to show we already have the
data and when we start bringing the
software sciences mind and soul
with the hardware sciences body and
brain
right you've got psychology and
neurology you bring those next level
medicine practices so regenerative
medicine with
the psychedelic therapies when you bring
those together now you've just created a
whole new medical framework that
actually gets to the root cause issues
and starts to help us transform better
than we ever thought imagined sick
absolutely sick dr dan engel ladies and
gentlemen a dose of hope a story of mdma
assisted psychotherapy will be linked in
the show notes below on amazon and if
people want to keep up to date with
whatever else you're doing where should
they go
uh yeah you can uh go to my website
that's one drdaneangle.com
full spectrum medicine i mentioned um
again it's a free platform i just want
to give people
information on this kind of work and
then kuya our center that opens in two
weeks is kuya.life
uh k-u-y-a
dot life l-i-f-e kuya means love and
quechua and so we want to continue to
give um
just mad respect to the origins of a lot
of these medicines and and the
communities where they've come from and
and have a good reciprocal
relationship to be able to give back to
the communities where a lot of these
medicines have have come from and make
sure that we're working with these
medicines in sustainable ways mdma
because it's
it's a synthetic we can
make that in a lab and scale that in
mass um but many of the other medicines
peyote ayahuasca san pedro
five amigo dmt from the sonoran desertos
iboga these are all natural medicines
that take a long time to grow and we're
harvesting at accelerated rates that are
stripping out our supply i had uh i had
hamilton morrison uh about six months
ago just after
as his vice series his most recent one
um oh sorry his hamilton's pharmacopoeia
i don't know if it's still done by vice
as that was on and obviously he was very
very
forward about trying to save the buffalo
various
uh about
proposing that people use a synthetic
version of five meo instead of
an organic version so it's it's
beautiful when you see everything
multiple people within similar
industries or analogous industries
coalescing around similar talking points
talking about sustainability within the
plant medicine world uh it definitely
seems like that's going to be a huge
push over the next few years
yeah
i
it has to be
because if not then we're going to
lose
a lot of the
the traditions
that have been in place for hundreds and
thousands of years
and
it's it's irresponsible to the coming
generations
have we have the opportunity to work
with these really powerful very
beautiful and sacred technologies
and how
how do we live sustainably i mean you
know it's the same relationship with our
fossil fuels with the ocean
acidification with like blah blah blah
we can fill in the gap like how do we
continue to live in right relation
with the medicine kingdom with the
traditional cultures and communities
with all people and also be mindful of
our impact for the generations to come
so i'm so glad i didn't see that
uh from hamilton but he's he's always
got a good story to tell and and and i
appreciate his story around
sustainability
done thanks so much for eddie
yeah absolutely chris thanks for having
me on man thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace
you